hello everyone uh welcome to document
session so we're very happy to have
ios jane with us from nt research
talking about documentation and learning
thank you so uh today i'm going to talk
about indistinguishability obfuscation
and learning problems
so one of the really nice thing about
this relationship between learning
theory and cryptography is this unique
kind of relationship of symbiosis
what we as cryptographers do we take
many of your learning problems which
have been studied for a very long time
and for which we don't know optimal
algorithms yet and we sometimes turn
them into extremely powerful and
surprising uh cryptographic primitives
at the same time in order for our search
for those kind of primitives we also
come up with new conjectures new
problems on which you can kind of base
security upon and that's that serves as
um a really nice test bench for some of
those algorithms
so today in this uh talk i'm going to
talk about indistinguishability
obfuscation
and it's a really versatile and
powerful and fundamentally really basic
object which has received a lot of
attention over the last 10 years or so
and i'm going to tell you how underlying
the security notions are hard problems
which have deep connections to learning
theory
okay so let's get started
first let's start by defining what is
indistinguishability obfuscation
added truths it was kind of implicitly
mentioned in 1976 in the work of davian
hellman but really the kind of main
thrust came through the work uh in
barack at all 2001.
what does it say
it's asking for something really basic
let's say you have a program and you can
think of it as a boolean circuit for for
the rest of the talk
and what uh
and what you're asking for is kind of a
compiler which i'm going to denote by in
io what does it do it's a polynomial
time compiler it outputs another program
think of it as a circuit again
this
this resulting circuit should basically
have the same input output behavior
meaningly meaning that this compiler
shouldn't change the functionality uh it
could be at least at most polynomially
slower but what we are really looking
for in this resulting circuit is some
kind of unintelligibility guarantees
about the implementation details of
the initial program okay and uh the way
io captures it is by asking that this
compiler enable hiding implementation
differences
so how do you formalize that
um think of two program spy and lambda
and let's say they satisfy
this premise of being functionally
equivalent
what does this functional equivalent
means
it means that these two programs have
the same input output behavior
and they all have also have the same
circuit size this is just some common
sense requirement
but what could be different the
different could be you know how they are
actually implemented and their gate
topology and so on so forth
so what io says is that if you have two
programs spy and lambda and let's say
they
satisfy this premise once i owe them
uh what i should get are two programs
that are hard to
distinguish or tell apart by a
computationally bounded or polynomial
time uh algorithm
okay so just this basic guarantee so in
the sense it's hiding implementation
differences and just to kind of drive
away the point home uh think of pi as
being the bubble sort program and lambda
being the selection star program both of
these programs are the kind of sorting
circuits
their functionality is identical but
their implementations are different so
io says uh if i offer scale let's say
bubble sort and give it to you you won't
be able to tell me for sure whether it
was bubble sort or selection sort or
some other uh starting process
okay so
now if you kind of uh
stare at for a while it may not be even
clear
why uh just hiding implementation
differences is the most theoretical
theoretically optimal kind of
unintelligibility guarantee that you can
ever hope for in any you know
an intelligibility compiler that i
mentioned um but turns out this pro this
took us quite some time it's only in
2007 when the work of
goldwater and rothland proved that you
know i was the best possible definition
that you can ever hope to realize
so and indeed uh even an application
standpoint we have seen
by no exaggeration
hundreds of results since the first work
in 2014 today we know that almost all
known cryptographic primitives and i'm
using almost all cryptographic
primitives uh today can be constructed
using io and additionally assuming some
kinds of other standard crypto so not
only classical primitives which we knew
how to do otherwise
um
you can build some
unimaginable like super powerful
primitives which people did not even
consider uh before i o came
because the kind of guarantees that they
were asking for is just like you too
much uh to be to hope for
um and it's really versatile
a single primitive implying so many
different things
so you know let's ask if it's so useful
what has been done in the community in
terms of construction
and here too there have been lots and
lots of work
the first construction came only in 2013
which is a candidate construction and
since then there have been many many
constructions new proposals new
conjectures
and then the security was based on those
conjectures and then there are cycles of
breaks and repair so this has really
seen
a lot of work
and
up until very recently we actually did
not even know if it's feasible to
realize i o uh based on some well
studied or reasonably well believed kind
of hard problem
so it was all kind of uh
open and this you know just tremendous
amount of work i can't even hope to
cover all of that in detail
but very broadly speaking
uh there are two kinds of lines that
have been emerging out
one line is kind of unique in the way
that in the sense that they rely on what
is known as elliptic curve cryptography
which i'm sure some of you might have
heard that many of the known public
encryption schemes which are used today
in like practice actually rely on
elliptic curve cryptography
this line uh recently you know you know
joint work with rachel in amit sahi we
can show that you can construct i o
based on three kind of computational
problems uh and two of them have a nice
learning theoretic feel to it
first problem is existence of boolean
prgs in nc 0.
so benny actually mentioned about this
in in his talk this is actually deeply
related to the notion of random csps
the second problem is the notion of
learning parity with noise over zp which
is exactly very closely related with
decoding random linear codes with sparse
noise and third of course is elliptic
curve cryptography
so what's nice about this is now that we
have some sort of confidence in the
feasibility of this uh
primitive if you assume that these kind
of problems are
hard
however what's what's actually annoying
and unfortunate that
one of the assumptions we make which is
the existence of
hard elliptic groups
turns out actually that's broken in
quantum polynomial time simply due to
period finding or shorts algorithm and
things like that so
this line cannot hope to give
a post quantum secure construction
unless we get rid of elliptic curve
cryptography and from the list
on the other hand there's another kind
of direction
what's so nice about them is they don't
do not rely on any kind of groups at all
and only rely on certain kind of lattice
decoding problems new but
they're entirely lattice based
problems so
it's possible that one day we might be
able to construct io
which is post quantum secure entirely
relying on uh on lattices
okay
now this has also seen a lot of work
last one year or so has been
really prolific in this kind of work
there have been five constructions and
one work which kind of finalized some of
those proposals
what's so nice about this kind of line
is that recently we have been seeing
some kind of emergence of a common high
level structure on those new kind of
problems and typically it ends up being
some kind of interaction between
learning with error which is a really
well known cryptographic problem
along with that there are some
structured leakages on the errors of
those lwe sample and typically this ends
up being some kind of low degree
polynomial
okay uh and the whole ball game here is
to exactly identify what kind of uh
simplest possible low degree polynomial
suffice for constructing
indistinguishability observation and at
the same time
can can be analyzed using learning
algorithms in like learning theory and
other kinds of algorithms which
which are typically studied to
cryptanalyze systems
so this is really new and exciting
lots of work needs to be done
holy grail here is of course if you
could construct io entirely on some kind
of lattice assumption without any kind
of leakage but it's actually really
important that we
identify clean
conjectures and then study them using
current framework of algorithms
and reason about them and this is one
place where i would feel that there will
be a revenue for collaboration between
the two communities
so that's all i'll say about these two
lines today in this talk i'm going to
focus on two problems
namely boolean prgs and nc 0 and
learning parity with noise over zp uh in
the interest of time i won't be able to
cover the
the other line although i'm really
excited about them and i'm happy to talk
offline about some of the key kind of
issues that arise in these constructions
okay so
let's start with uh our first
uh problem boolean prgs in nc 0. and um
so what are boolean phrases and so
they're extremely simple boolean
functions what do they do they take n
bits of input so so they take n bits of
input and
they they have m outputs and where m is
actually more than n and actually for to
be useful to i o it needs to be actually
polynomial and n so you're looking at
polynomially expanding boolean functions
and we also need these functions to be
evaluable by by constant f circuit so
every output bit can only depend on a
constant number of
input bits and that's called the
locality
what we are really looking for is
cryptographic security we want that when
the prgg is evaluated at a random input
x this should be computationally
indistinguishable to random string uh r
of length m uh now typically in in the
learning world uh the it's it's
important to kind of specify what kind
of definition we are hoping for so what
we're really hoping for is that for
every polynomial time attacker uh
probability that adversely takes this g
of x and outputs one uh minus the
probability that adversary
and polynomial time attacker takes a
random string of length m and outputs
1 they should be really
cryptographically small and by
cryptographically small i mean extremely
small sub-exponential energy 2 to the
minus n to this constant for some
constant and this is where i want to
kind of stress some differences which
arise in typical learning settings and
our setting we are trying to do show
this for every possible polynomial time
attacker unless
and not some restricted class and also
the kind of distinguishing probability
we're shooting for is 2 to the minus n
to the omega 1 whereas typical learning
prgs
uh also consider where this
unconditional prg is also considered
settings where this is inverse
polynomial
so this problem has been you know
studied for a long time i'm sure you
heard benny stock and he was mentioning
this at the great bit of detail
at least 20 years we have seen lots of
lots of different candidates and what
kind of
algorithms that go into building it so
today in this talk what we're going to
do
we're going to look at these boolean
prgs in nc 0 and i'm going to show that
how the current known
constructions are heavily inspired for
from the notion of random csps but then
how things starts to change and how what
are the other kind of additional issues
that we have to deal which typically do
not arise in the csp settings
and then what else needs to be done
by the way if there are any questions
please just stop me and ask away
so how do you build uh candidate boolean
pijs in nc 0
uh the most popular paradigm in fact
that's the only one i'm aware of
is uh this general recipe by goldrich in
2001 which was actually to construct one
one-way functions but actually this also
is a
reasonable recipe to build the prgs so
what does it say
uh a gold right prg is actually indexed
kind of parameterized by two things one
of them is a boolean predicate and it's
a balanced predicate uh meaning half of
the inputs go to zero half of the inputs
go to one and it only depends on some
constant number of bits
and then there is a hyper graph there's
a bipolar graph
how is this bipartite graph chosen well
there are on the left side of versus i'm
going to just write 1 through n which
are the nodes n is the number of inputs
on the right hand sides
we have
m
kind of
vertices each of them
are connected to
d of the
left vertices
and you can also write it in a hyper
graph notation x1 through sm m
corresponds to the number of output bits
that you are hoping for now how is this
graph chosen typically it's chosen at
random
all it needs to do is satisfy some kind
of expansion at least it needs to
satisfy some kind of expansion
guarantees and uh that is very specific
to exact uh d exact m and all those kind
of things which i'm not going to cover
uh you heard all of that in benny's talk
but um the idea is that it needs to be
an expander and therefore some sort of
conditions need to be satisfied uh and
if it's randomly chosen with very good
probability it ends up being an expander
okay so now once you have this graph and
this predicate you can define this
function which is indexed with the
predicate in the graph uh
which takes an input x and it outputs uh
m bits y one through y m and each y i is
computed by applying the predicate p on
the inputs corresponding to the set si
so this is the ith output bit
and then the prg conjecture says
if you choose this predicate p pop
properly for whatever
properly means and if the graph has some
nice combinatorial properties then
this function is going to yield a secure
prg
so
now from what you saw this figure uh
this this drawing that i drew should be
very reminiscent of kind of structure
that arises in csp as well in a random
csp uh it's actually associated with the
same kind of
it's really similar in that setting the
apparatus is very very similar so it's
very uh natural that you might want to
use some of the results that you have
studied random csps for a very very long
time you might want to use them in order
to construct a prg so let's you know
dive a little bit on uh this intuition
so let's say you have a random csp how
is defined again the same apparatus
there is a hypergraph h with delta n
edges where delta is the constraint
density again this is there is a
balanced constant local predicate p
which takes d bits and outputs one bit
and
think of b greater than equal to three
then uh random csp typically is
associated with two kinds of
distribution the first one is planted
in a planted distribution what you do
you sample an input x star from 0 1 to
the n at random then you're going to
issue m constraints
one constraint for every
uh set s i
okay so how is it each constraint
generated you're going to sample a
random negation pattern c i from 0 1 to
d and you're going to choose a boolean
variable flip
which is the probability which with i
will flip the constraint uh typically
it's chosen from a bernoulli
distribution with a tiny probability rho
which is a constant
and then you can generate each
constraint by giving out ci along with a
value bi which consists of the predicate
p applied on
the bits of x star corresponding to the
set s i but then uh flipped according to
the negation pattern
and then uh you will you're going to put
out the sample with this event flip i
that you just sampled so this is the
planted distribution and then there is a
random distribution where you don't
choose any planted input at all you
simply output
ci and
a random value array chosen obliviously
of any uh planted input
so this is the setting of random csp and
you study a variety of problems
uh concerning this uh all kind of
dealing with this notion of optimum
where um
you want to find out so optimum cons is
the objective which is the maximum
number of constraints that can be
satisfied by any given x
uh any given input x
so then you uh you for just to kind of
make some observation in the planted
case
the number of constraints that you can
satisfy is 1 minus 0 times m with very
high probability
and in the random case
if m is large enough you can never hope
for
more than 0.5 fraction uh of the
assignments by being satisfied by any
input if m is large enough
rho is the probability of flipping and
that's why this row comes in
so uh
you can ask a variety of questions in
the search
problem you're trying to find the
planted assignment uh
and then on the other hand which is the
exactly opposite of doing search uh you
what you're trying to show is that if i
take a random uh instance
not you can you're trying to give a
proof that not too many of those can be
simultaneously satisfied by any given x
so it's a
it's you you're going to write a proof
and typically this
entails that you're going to try to come
up with an algorithm r which is a
refuter which has the following
guarantee first it needs to take as
input uh the csp and it it should output
an upper bound on the number of
constraints that can be satisfied by any
given input
but then into ensure non-triviality
you're going to ask that with some
constant probability for example
the value at outputs needs to be less
than one minus delta where delta is some
constant again
so this is called called as delta
refutation
okay so uh and then there is another
version of the problem which is
distinguishing which you would believe
is easier than the two here you are
trying to just distinguish between the
planted and the random kids
so now all the three problems have been
studied for a long time and there's some
kind of intuition that
all of these problems should be hard if
you set the parameters uh appropriately
so
it's trivial to see that the search and
the refutation versions
is easier than distinguishing you can
make a very simple distinguisher by if
you have a algorithm that succeeds in
either search or refutation
on the other hand what's so what's even
surprising is that under some parameters
uh distinguishing turns out to be as
hard as search so if you have a
like a reasonably powerful distinguisher
you can use it uh
to also do search i'm going to refer you
to benny's talk because he talked about
it in a bit of detail more detail
so all these problems are supposed to be
kind of roughly intuitively same kind of
hardness class and in fact this has been
looked for a long time uh phi gay gave
his famous hypothesis where he said that
when
the number of constraints is like
constant time sent for for large enough
constant then there is a no no
polynomial time refutation algorithm for
random reset and as of now this is far
from
being refuted as as much as i know
and today the there are explicit
examples of predicates
uh for which the best known algorithms
in fact take sub exponential time
um
when m is let's some polynomial in n and
kind of if m is even as large as n to
the d over two minus epsilon the best
known algorithms today are sub
sub-exponential for those predicates
so which means that you know csps have
been studied for a long time you it's
very intuitive that you might want to
build prg starting from that intuition
so our goal is to kind of take an
appropriate version of csp kind of
massage it into a construction of for
prg and remember we are hoping to uh
get polynomial stretch
so before we you know proceed further
let me kind of point out some
high level issues
which are not big
deal but we still need to address them
one of the issues is that typically
what we want we when we want a prg with
a very small cryptographically small
advantage distinguishing probability
this you cannot hope in general from
csps
from random csps but just because
um
so it turns out when you choose
the graph at random
with inverse polynomial probability
it'll turn out to be an extremely bad
graph which will trivially make this
problem very easy for example it might
happen that the set s1 which is the
first
constraint set
turns out to be equal with 2s2 with very
noticeable probability and therefore the
first two constraint might end up being
correlated so this is an issue
but typically this is easy to deal with
we will we will ensure
that
we kind of give these guarantees only
when the graph is uh nice which will
happen with very large probability
close to one
when the graph is chosen at random so
we're going to
from whatever i'm going to say think of
the graph being chosen from nice enough
distribution
second issue is
how do i select the which balanced
predicate to use the answer to this
question is really simple you're going
to choose dxr and why is that
the reason is actually very nice
turns out when we con when we consider
refutations
um dxr is actually as hard as any other
csps under certain class of reputation
algorithm
the reason is extremely simple again
so you're going to consider a predicate
b
uh let's say it's k local so it depends
on k outputs then the claim is that um
you know due to simple kind of uh
analysis of fourier analysis of boolean
functions you can show that there will
exist a subset s of k
let's say the size of that set is d such
that the predicate actually ends up
being correlated with the
with the linear term corresponding to
the set s and the correlation is
actually more than 2 to the minus q 2.
this you can show using simple analysis
of boolean functions
and the point of this is that once you
have this
no matter what csp you start to start
with you can transform the planted
instance where there are one minus row
fraction satisfied constraints into a
dxr instance
which
which has about point five plus two to
the minus k over two satisfied
constraints
therefore if you couldn't you know do a
strong refutation very powerful
definition for dxr it will let you do a
weak refutation for p
okay so
any questions
okay
so um so which means that the xor is a
really nice uh starting predicate for
our journey of uh exploration on how to
you know try and build prgs from csps
so
turns out random dxors have been studied
for a long time and many also mentioned
in a great bit of detail so i'm not
going to spend too much time there have
been lots of csp i'm i'm going to call
all these classes of algorithm as
conventional csp algorithms
uh have been studied for a long time and
what's nice about these algorithms is
that they typically have this threshold
behavior uh what's this threshold
behavior it so turns out that if i set m
to be slightly more than n two d over
two then all of these algorith then
these algorithms end up breaking the the
uh
the csps
uh but when i
reduce the number of samples from an
into the tube d by two to a tiny amount
let's say indeed d over 2 minus epsilon
then these all of these
problems exhibit harden all of these
algorithms exhibit hardness and the best
known algorithms take some exponential
time
and what's also very nice is that they
don't even care about the noise so if
our planted
input
had no noise it would have these kind of
algorithms still fail in order to give a
secure instance
so in order to break an instance of
csp
so which means
our first candidate is just noiseless
dxr and let's try and see what happens
so
now if i uh
you can already see the problem here if
i choose my predicate to be x1 through
xt which is the dxr
this you cannot hope to construct a
secure prg out of this because our
biggest worry is is just a very simple
algorithm of caution elimination
so it's really you know prone to algebra
and why did this
did not apply in the case of csps was
just
uh because we had this flipping variable
where we were trying we were at random
flipping those equations and uh those
turns out that flip actually just throws
out all the algebraic attacks in the
water and we don't have to worry about
them however
what we are trying to do here we do not
have this additional noise to play with
or to design our prg our goal is to
construct new randomness not to use that
randomness to make our
instance secure
and this turns out to be really really
hard in fact most cryptographic
proposals that are proposed for like
various kinds of constructions
typically they uh
they
they're when they're broken they're it's
always or most of the times it's always
algebra it's never
it's very rare to see a sophisticated
algorithm like sum of squares which ends
up
attacking these uh these assumptions
okay so how do you get around this the
idea which which has been actually
existence existing since 2003 uh is that
we use this uh non-linear term
inside the predicate and the hope is
that this kind of mimics or does what
exactly the csb noise does
for this case for the case of csbs okay
and
now if i can choose this non-linear
predicate so that
you you can
take care of algebraic attacks that will
mean like we have found a nice candidate
for prg
so in the rest of this talk we're going
to exactly
see how to choose this nonlinear
predicate so that you can rule out
certain kind of algebraic attacks
okay so
uh
okay so just to kind of take
the message home
so this was our predicate and now what
we are trying to do we again trying to
observe how to choose the normal
predicate and note that just because i
have this linear term here uh the
previous
algorithms from the csp algorithms suit
they they kind of fail even when m is
chosen at large as n to the d over 2
minus epsilon and by fail i mean i'm
looking for a polynomial time algorithm
to solve this
okay so
now
our goal is to find this non-linear
predicate so so that you can prove
security against algebraic attacks and
in our in our goal we'll try to we'll
try to see how you can choose non-linear
predicates so that the stretch is at
least polynomial because that's what we
need for io but i really would like to
support the stretch of n to the constant
times d one should be able to choose
this tunable parameter d and just get as
much stretch as they want
okay and i really would like to touch
even n to the d over two because that's
what the csp like that's what the bound
we have from the other uh set of
algorithms
okay so before we you know even start to
understand how to pick this predicate we
must understand what algebraic attacks
have been studied and you know how do
you even capture them
so it turns out there are kind of two
kinds of attacks one of them is linear
bias attacks
which captures the notion of
distinguisher which are computed with uh
which only take like linear combinations
of the outputs of the prg
so here the goal of the adversary
is to find a combination which i'm going
to denote by test
and uh
the test should be such that
when uh someone exhausts the combination
correspond to uh that test those
combinations
an expectation should be biased in
probability because this shouldn't
happen when the outputs are random
and in order to you know bypass those
attacks
or prove guarantee against those attacks
you prove that the the function is a
small bias generator in which you have
to prove that once you fix the graph and
the predicate then for
with
for every such combination
all of those combinations that adversely
can ever come up with
it should happen that xor of those
outputs
if at all they are biased the bias
should not be more than sub exponential
and answer it shouldn't be more than 2
to the minus n to the constant for some
constant
so that's what we are trying to prove
i want to emphasize that it's for every
such test that you can adversely can
come up with
so for a long time it was thought that
you know these are the only kinds of
attacks that one has to worry about and
when it comes to algebra uh this change
in 2016 where the work of apple bomb and
lobbit they showed a new class of
attacks which realizes which utilizes
polynomial uh calculus system and the
idea was they crucially made use of high
degree algebraic manipulations on the on
the on the prg outputs to derive new and
new equations and then uh using
algebraic refutations they were able to
uh attack a version of prg which was
actually known to be unbroken using
linear bias so
it just strictly proves that this is a
new class of attacks which which we
hadn't considered before
and typically in order to you know argue
security against such attacks what you
want to do you want to prove algebraic
refutation lower bounds
so now we're going to you know identify
some of the key properties of the
non-linear predicate so that you know
you can
prove uh security against these two
kinds of uh
attacks and typically these proofs are
really combinatorial they rely on
properties of the predicate as well as
the graph
and
and uses techniques from analysis of
boolean functions and all those things
uh so we're going to study at on a very
high level of course i can't go in
detail and
how exact those proofs work but i'm
going to give you some kind of intuition
and this intuition is not only important
and in the case of prgs
this is kind of a general problem in the
sense that many a times when we devise
new systems and new assumptions we need
to analyze all these things which uh
becomes hard owing to the fact that
these proofs are extremely combinatorial
and extremely specific to the problem so
one of the open problems i'm going to
like
pitch
is this you know if you could understand
uh or make this uh make this kind of
line really clean so that one can simply
come up with an assumption and say that
uh you know this this satisfies these
these criterias and
and therefore it's kind of immune to
algebraic attacks
okay
so let's look at
linear attacks and just to recall this
is what we want to do how do you choose
non-linear predicate
well
the first guess
let's pick any predicate of your choice
just and just just take any nonlinear
predicate what you want whatever you
want
does this give you any any sort of small
questionnaire and the answer to that
question is uh partially yes in the
sense that if the number of outputs is n
to the 1.25
then you can actually provably show that
this
will behave like a small bias generator
now remember we wanted to get a stretch
of n to the constant times d for some
for some constant is this possible the
answer to that is that not with
arbitrary predicate of your choice
because if i choose a predicate uh nl
which has slow degree let's say constant
uh then i can't hope security when m is
greater than n to the c because of
linearization
why do you why do you want into the
omega d like what you know why can't you
just come you could just usually compose
prgs and then you get yeah you you'll
get a squared trade off you want you i
think you'll get if if you want uh if
you compose d times you will get
something like n to the root of d i'm
just asking for optimality
uh what's the optimum you could do
because uh
at least in the csp world we have this
very sharp threshold uh enter the door
to broken and then before that that's
like secure we want to just do kind of
kind of same kind of uh
reasoning about
this that's reasonable
just to get a sense of what the
applications are but for cryptographic
applications
do you care about the d versus sorry
for cryptographic applications do you
care about the end of the d versus just
polynomial stretch or this is just to
get
worry about optimality which is also
important i'm aware of only one example
where the optimality was important
so in in our construction uh in europe
21 on um on io
we required a prg with uh with
with integer degree d integer degree i'm
not talking about the f2 degree and the
stretch needed to be more than n to the
d over four
[Music]
because that
at that time we did not when this paper
came out we did not know this new i o
result that i was talking about
so those were based on new kinds of
assumptions and one of those assumptions
required uh this d by four tradeoff got
it thanks
okay so
okay so as i was saying if i choose
non-union predicate to be degree c uh
you can't hope to a security difference
to this like my name is greater than
greater than equal to n to the c
what about you know how do i so this
means that a degree needs to be high
what if i choose the largest possible
degree predicate where the nonlinear
particle is just product of d things uh
turns out uh let alone uh stretch that
depends on d it's actually broken when
uh when there are n to the 2.1 outputs
and actually it's a really simple and
acute idea by by al-16 and what do they
do
they
they show that you know what you can do
you can simply collect n to the 1.1
outputs say
such that these outputs have a common
structure namely that these outputs are
computed by applying the predicate p on
inputs
bits of x corresponding to the set s i
such that the set s i in the non-linear
term share a variable let's say x1 so
they have a common structure with one
variable in common in the nonlinear term
x1
what does this mean
with 0.5 probability
if the input is chosen at random it will
happen
that x 1 becomes 0 and then this these
are all linear equations so you get n to
the 1.1 linear equations
and you can solve for x
so that was the problem and then you
can't hope for a stretch even into the
2.1
so which means so so what what went
wrong
uh well it turns out that it's not the
just the degree
uh it needs to be the bit fixing degree
that needs to be high and just to kind
of define what bit fixing degree mean
i'm going to say our bit fixing degree
of predicate p
is e
if
uh i take predicate p and over arbitrary
fixing of
up to until our bits of p
the minimum degree i get
is e
okay as an example if i choose this as
the non-linear predicate
then the one bit fixing degree of that
predicate is actually one because i can
substitute xd plus one as zero and then
that fixing the degree actually becomes
it the predicate becomes linear
so what a l showed if i have our bit
fixing degree of predicate p e
then actually it's broken when the
number of output bits grow more than n
to the r plus c okay it's just the same
idea
but actually what's so nice is that they
showed that this is also sufficient in
the sense
that if our bit fixing degree of p is e
where both are near large
then you indeed get a small bias
generator supporting n to the constant
times d
okay
so as a conclusion all you need to do is
choose a nonlinear predicate with a
large weight fixing degree and you can
choose majority for your nonlinear term
which has d by 4 bit fixing degree of d
by 4.
however i want to stress that in this
proof
there's a huge gap i'm hiding very big
constants here in this sigma
so there's a gap there's a big regime in
which we neither know attacks
nor can we prove security
at least as of now
okay so this is kind of also the theme
which will come out later on in in in
other kinds of prgs
okay
so
now the question remains
uh is the small bias attacks uh the only
kind of attacks that i need to worry
about when it comes to algebra
the answer to that is
no there is at least one the polynomial
calculus one
and uh
it's also acute insight the idea is that
think of a predicate p which has large
bit fixing degree
okay so
it has large bit fixing degree and as a
consequence of that uh it's small bias
but let's say hypothetically speaking it
so turns out
that i can find two small degree
predicates q and r let's say they're
degrees e
such that when i multiply p with q
suddenly the degree reduces to e uh e
meaning i result in another predicate
which is which is also low degree and as
an example uh r is a high high degree
predicate but when i multiply it with x1
i get x1 you can see when x1 is 1 both
of both the sides are 1 if x1 is 0 then
both the sides are 0. so this equation
is kind of satisfied
uh so this is an example where this
happens so the point is if i can fi if
our predicate has this property
uh
then you can form some equations like
this so you had samples y 1 through y m
you can multiply it with the q
and you get r these are algebraic
equations in degree e
and now if q and r have
some requirements then actually you can
linearize it
but um but if if that's not the case al
actually uh apple bombing love it they
showed that uh
you can do some clever arguments to do
polynomial refutations in general
okay so it cannot be secured when m is
greater than
uh n to the e okay by the way uh this
degree e which i'm gonna i was
mentioning is actually called the
rational degree uh the minimum degree
for which you can multiply p with so you
get a lower degree polynomial r
okay
so
um and it's not it's not just like uh
uh like a proof thing actually you can
give explicit counter examples consider
this predicate which has about d plus d
square variables don't have to stare
deeply on the predicate i'm just going
to explain you clearly quickly it has uh
d things in the linear term and then it
ex or
d things where every thing is a r of d
things okay so uh it's not hard to
verify that it has d minus one bit
fixing degree d
uh but
uh but actually it has rational degree
two
true so that uh so so it's in fact
broken when uh in terms of algebraic
attacks with n squared
okay so
uh
here again in this algebraic kind of
polynomial uh calculus based
refrigerations
uh el showed a really nice theorem
showing
that if the rational degree e is high
then you get a stretch of uh n to the e
uh with respect to algebraic attacks
okay but here as well there is a huge
gap between what you can prove and what
you can
what you can
prove secure and what you can attack and
i'm going to bring exact constants in
just a minute
okay so to summarize
how do i pick my predicate i'm going to
pick this predicate as an xor of uh
there's a linear term which has d things
and then i'm going to uh x sorted with
the nonlinear term
and as you've already seen
you know uh csp algorithms are going to
fail with n to the b over 2 minus
epsilon
uh how do i choose so that it's immune
to algebraic attacks it needs to have
high fixing degree and a high rational
degree turns out higher actually just a
question uh so
do you have some intuition why there is
no some some other algebraic attack i
mean you said you knew like how did you
define your mind that's a great
accomplishment
small bias attacks
it's more of a distinguisher so what's
going on is that you're
taking a linear combination and trying
to
produce
a leica term which is biased and that
gives you a distinguisher
algebraic refutations
are doing algebraic manipulation
uh and trying to derive a constraint one
equal to zero
which is a contradiction
uh
you can ask
can you can you somehow build a attack
which utilizes both these properties try
yeah andre do you want to say something
a more unified way to think about the
two
so one way to sort of there is an
alternative definition of the
algebraic
attacks sort of you split the part of
the output each output bit is either one
or zero so either take the one output or
the zero outputs and then sort of
condition on some outputs being zero
i get some system of polynomial
equations for each output
so i can kind of use this information
that i know which outputs are one and
which outputs are zero when i set the
equation so it's more general in that
sense
but is these results able to refute
every such
kind of attack
that reduces it to solving the system of
polynomial equations over gf2
is that
i i thought there is uh one of the
questions that this paper
left is uh is an explicit so if you look
at the paper they have an explicit
question where they give giving another
kind of attack which their uh
lower bounds does not capture
so there is more to it yeah there is
more to it definitely
uh
okay
so uh where was i okay great so in order
so you need to choose a non-linear
predicate which has high rational degree
which is actually enough so you can
choose
majority which has the rational degree
of div by two and just uh
and this is just to kind of illustrate
the gap here um even if n to the d over
two minus epsilon we don't know of any
heuristic attacks including algebraic
attacks uh but the provable lower bounds
are only 10 to the d over 38 so there's
a huge gap and
we'd like to understand why is that is
it an artifact of the proof or
what can we do to fill this and explain
what happens between
okay so let me end this vrd segment on
broad open questions one of the open
questions which i would really like to
understand is that this so far the way i
presented is that there you start from
an intuition of csp and then things
start to different uh to defer that
there is a
that we have to worry about algebraic
attacks which do not exist in the csp
uh landscape can you build a prg which
is at least as secure as a csp
uh random csp with noise can you build a
prg which has this property and
that will actually rule out a lot of
algebraic attacks if you can give a
formal kind of relationship between the
two
another is this i have already mentioned
the tighter characterization uh the very
few works uh which
on algebraic attacks so can you actually
give a tighter characterization and as
uh
there was a question just now about
other attacks so
so if you can
analyze other kind of attacks which
we haven't haven't yet studied or we are
yet to study
so in the in the remaining time let's
let me talk about another problem which
is played a major pivotal role in the
construction of obfuscation a
fascinating uh problem learning parity
with noise and has it roots back in 1950
to the work uh on coding theory
uh so what does it say
it says that you know take a matrix a
think of it as a random matrix in
dimension
m cross n so
m is much more than n so m you're
looking at a very tall and a thin matrix
now what do i do uh and by the way for
the field you can think of f2 or
whatever field you want
most studied setting is f2
so then you multiply your secret s
from
zp to the n
and you take this combination now at
this point if i give you a and this
combination a and s
and i ask you to solve for s or d code s
it's really easy you can simply run
question elimination and solve for it
lpn is exact same question with an
additional twist what's the twist i'm
going to perturb few of these samples
with
tiny constant probability rho
okay so i'm going to what i'm how how do
i do this i'm going to sample a vector e
of dimension m where every coordinate is
independently sampled to be random from
zp with probability rho
rho is some parameter
and with one minus row it's going to
it's set to zero
okay and i'll give you b and i asked the
same question given a and b can you
decode s for me
now this row is typically a tunable
parameter 0 to 0.99
and this kind of governs what kind of
hardness
do you get for this problem so this is
known as search lpn and note that
you can actually find
a secret s uniquely
as long as the number of samples m is
large enough how large if you do some
calculation you can show that it needs
to be linear in n
um in cryptography we study a weaker
variant of this problem or we use weaker
variant of for this problem which is
known as decision lpn here you want to
distinguish a and b from a an uniform
okay instead of b generated this way i
give you a uniform
okay so what are the settings that are
studied in cryptography are used in
cryptography typically field f2 the the
sample complexity is
polynomial although sub exponential
complexity is also
used in some of the constructions
and what about noise well there are two
uninteresting regimes
uh when the noise is one by n here you
could like simply guess n linearly
independent equations and you can solve
for it so it's broken polynomial time
the other extreme when rho is one in
which case
the problems uh the distributions become
identical and there is no problem at all
other than that all other parameters
have been
used in cryptography so the most
conservative setting is high noise lpn
where the row is constant
the best known algorithms here take
close to exponential time
uh the intermediate problem which is
slightly more interesting in terms of
applications uh low noise lpn where the
noise is 1 by n to the delta where delta
is
some constant between 0 and 1.
just to give you a sense for i o we need
the setting of 1 by n to the 0.001 i
mean the delta can be arbitrary constant
greater than 0.
and for public
encryption the best known schemes that
we have
rely on noise setting of n to the minus
point five okay and typically when the
delta increases the problem becomes
easier and easier
um the best known algorithms in this
regime are sub exponential
finally
also studied also used extremely low
noise lpn where rho is
poly log n divided by n
and here the algorithms take a
quasipolynomial time
so these are the typical settings
since we are working with since
cryptographers care a lot about
distinguishing problem one thing really
nice about this
problem is that there are decision and
search equivalences
um actually you can easily show that if
you have a distinguisher a powerful
enough distinguisher you can use it to
actually search uh for the secret and
the idea is just typically a basic
extension of a simple idea which i can
just maybe tell you in a couple of
minutes uh the idea is that let's say i
have a distinguisher and i want to guess
the secret s or completely figure out
the secret test and let's say the field
is f2
i can take an lpn sample which looks
like a and a s plus c and a is a one
through a n
uh i can you know one bit by bit peel
off the secret and how let's say i want
to guess the first bit of secret
and consider this new new sample that i
generate which is a prime which consists
of the prefix of a from 2 to n so really
i removed a1 from the vector
and i did on the right hand the other
side a s plus e which is what i had and
i subtracted off a1 times s1
guess
now the point is if i made a correct
guess of my secret then it turns into
another lpn in one dimension less
and if i made the guess wrong then
actually this becomes a random sample
because a1 was random
so if i have a distinguisher you know i
can
learn the secret bits one by one uh
and typically you know you need to boost
this simple reduction many many times to
get more and more confidence on the
secret so reduction run time and sample
sample complexity grows in this trivial
argument
however there are sophisticated sample
preserving
algorithms which do not which have the
large reduction time but it doesn't have
such big of a sample complexity
okay and when it comes to algorithms lot
has a lot of work has been done
all of those algorithms typically are
either algebraic or like semi algebraic
but they have this algebraic flavor to
it
uh
and none of them actually
far exceed
the the best running times
uh that i can that often algorithm which
i'm going to tell you in the next
extremely simple algorithm which is the
guessing algorithm
so
in the guessing algorithm uh what do you
do you simply guess an errorless
equations
now if the probability of error is rho
you're able to guess n
error-less equations the probability is
1 minus rho to the power n
and therefore if you repeat it
1 minus rho to the power minus 10 times
you get more and more probability of
getting hang on the right rls equations
and solving using gaussian elimination
if you plug in the values when i choose
rho as constant i get 2 to the power
order n if i choose
rho to be 1 by into the delta i get 2 to
the power
order n minus
n to the one minus delta and if i choose
um
high noise setting then i get a
quasi-polynomial time algorithm
so this is really surprising this
problem has been there for a long time
and actually
if i just care about the asymptotic
complexity in the exponent
i can't do much better than this naive
algorithm
except one case which i'm going to
mention which is this breakthrough
result of blumkala in wasserman
what do they do
they can show that you know you can
solve constant rate lpn
if you can somehow increase the number
of samples to 2 to the n by over log n
which is really high
then you can solve this in the same time
so then this time and the sample
complexity is n
uh sorry is n uh 2 to the n over log n
therefore shaving off that log n factor
and the uh
unfortunately i don't have time to go
about how the bkw algorithm works
uh i'm happy to talk about it offline
though
um
and
actually this this work was also
a natural question to ask is what
happens when i restrict the
sample complexity to polynomial n to the
one plus epsilon then lube chef's key in
2005 showed that you can't get n to the
l i mean it doesn't go all the way to n
by log n it goes to 2 to the n by log
log n
okay and as far as i'm aware with
constant number of samples sorry linear
number of samples we don't know any such
results
so uh
another really important note which is
also one of the open questions which i'm
going to
say is just this algorithm is very
stellar made for to work on f2 this
somehow the kind of techniques that you
they're using
uh it's very tailor-made to work on f2
in fact we don't know any such
implication when the prime fields are
large
for i o actually turns out that we need
the field to be sub exponentially large
so all these kind of uh algorithms they
don't work in the setting that we are
using
okay so with this you know let me end uh
at some open question as i've been
mentioning we would like to understand
what happens at large field surprisingly
even after so many years of work we know
very little about this uh this problem
there have been um
like um
all do all the other algorithms that we
typically study are algebraic in nature
so if there are other algorithms we
don't know about that we don't know how
um hardness with respect to the primes
with respect to the fields rate does it
become harder or easier if i choose the
bigger prime
all those questions are
not yet clear
another very interesting direction which
has come up recently is about worst case
hardness here you want to prove that if
you can solve this lpn which is an
average case problem then uh it's
actually you you can use it to break
some kind of
variance of nearest code word problems
which is a worst case decoding problem
so that's a really nice emerging
direction and there is a lot to be done
in that space as well
so uh yeah other than i'm happy to you
know talk about these kind of things
offline so thanks for hearing and uh if
you have any questions i'm happy to take
them
yeah thanks for the very involvement
[Applause]
uh i guess we can ask first question
from the live audience and then we can
fast and zoom if there are any
right
the bilinear stuff
so all together there's a slide yeah i
can go back to that slide that's
the elliptic curves
so yeah these there are two kinds of uh
directions one
using pairing groups and that
has given this kind of assumptions and
this is still going on and uh
typically on a very high level they have
a structure
so lw
it's not that you need this and that
these are separate works these are these
are two uh two broad directions uh that
are popular right now in iris
most construction either fall in this
category or that category but do you
have more assumptions no than this uh in
which side these are two separate
directions right this is the on the
right on the side on the left i guess
your side on this side yes
so yeah we did have lwe before but now
which recently showed in the new world
that you you can get rid of lwe you
don't need it anymore so but but you
have learning parameters
oh i see so they differ i'm confused
so there are three assumptions there uh
buoyant
prgs in nc zero learning parity with
noise over zp and elliptic curve
cryptography yeah okay okay so the
reason the other side only has one is
because these guys also need the
learning parity with noise no they just
need the lw plus plus l w plus plus lw
and then some structured leakage on the
errors
okay and that's it i mean you know this
is very big assuming to i don't know
what infinite levels but that replaces
uh the learning parity with noises is
used for some kind of surrounding
which part is for the subatomic
generation
can you give us some idea of how which
assumption serves what purpose is yeah
yeah yeah
so essentially
for this line uh since you're using
billionaire maps we can do degree 2
computations turns out what we need to
do is a prg which is com which has short
short input and a longer output but it's
actually could be computable in degree
two
and somehow this mixture of
lpn if you use lpn and you use a prg and
c0 you can kind of combine them them to
build a prg which is which in the
preprocessing model like has can be well
can be computed by uh bilinear maps or
the in degree too so
that's why these two assumptions are
used along with
elliptic curves in fact if you had
degree two prgs
uh
which we don't know how to construct in
fact they are impossible then you can uh
remove the
then you can remove both these
assumptions and all you need is uh some
kind of just degree two prgs
the other side uses the power of
homomorphic encryption
so you want to evaluate a big circuit uh
using lwe style things you can evaluate
and at the end of the day
there is
uh right so then what you want to do is
you want to give a short kind of
decryption key which only enables
learning
uh
the output the corresponding outputs of
the truth table
uh and that short key is like some sort
of leakage which lets you this leakage
on the errors
so eating inside the leakage you are
making an assumption of the hardness
you're able to figure out the answer
yeah if you did not have leakage then
it's secure
and leakage lets you
gives you functionality but then you
have to make a new assumption that this
leakage is okay to give
right
so maybe
some other question may be from the zoom
or the live audience
uh if i can um i want to ask a question
uh sorry this is vinod uh
okay i'm coming from the sky
so so the first question i want to ask
is you know um the both lines of work on
constructing io uh seem to somehow rely
on hardness of csps or random to solving
random systems or polynomial equations
right
do you have a sense that this is
inherent or just sort of a quirk on the
way and you know eventually you know uh
it'll just disappear i guess what i'm
asking is is it worth spending the
effort
um to study these random polymer systems
uh if i'm a cryptographer you know will
it stay forever or
you know
so uh
i think i
i will
probably take some of it offline because
it's a long answer what i'm thinking but
uh somehow it's on a very high level it
seems that
uh the boolean struct even if you design
these polynomials
if the boolean structures are
the kind of boolean function
that i mean every polynomial is at the
end of the day
uh
will have some kind of uh
like a monomial pattern and that
monomial
pattern uh in some sense
in some of the settings which i was
thinking about transforms to
certain kind of boolean functions and if
those boolean i mean okay just to put it
in another way uh the polynomials that
arise typically um in some of the things
that i was trying out transform into
like give rise to
some kind of
boolean uh
functions and if those functions end up
being easy then you can use that to
attack the polynomial systems and uh
i'm happy to you know explain to you in
what i'm trying to say
so i in mind i would suspect that there
are some connections but it's too early
to say like
[Music]
necessarily or not um so i guess the
other question i have is sort of a more
detailed question so you mentioned the
bkw algorithm right um so uh you know
if you try to run bkw
over a large field but uh with a field
of characteristic two uh shouldn't it
just work you know like uh because you
know an equation over characteristic
over large characteristic to field is
just many questions in in you know like
mod two right um so that should just
work right uh
yeah although i'm not sure how the ring
structure because uh like this it's
typically f2x divided by some polynomial
and uh the multiplication will kind of
uh
i'll have to think some more but it's
plausible i'll maybe i can think offline
and get back
thanks
okay so maybe at the end of time we're
gonna take the rest of questions offline
uh thanks again